have you seen this before we begin with
another extraordinary moment in this
presidential election there have been a
few repeatedly upended by the pandemic
president Trump and Joe Biden helped
simultaneous Prime Time Town Halls where
they face voters questions on a number
of issues the events replaced the second
presidential debate after president
Trump declined to participate virtually
and voters at home were forced to choose
or Channel surf between the two Town
Halls which had very different tones
we've got a team of correspondents
covering these dual events now just 18
days before the election and we're going
to begin with Nicole Killian at the
White House covering the president's
Town Hall Nicole Nicole good morning to
you good morning Tony it was an
eye-opening performance from the
president he refused to denounce a
dangerous conspiracy theory and appear
to make stunning admissions about his
financial records
I didn't feel good I didn't feel strong
I had a little bit of a temperature at
his town hall president Trump answered
questions about his coveted symptoms and
whether or not he had pneumonia no but
they said the lungs are you know a
little bit different a little bit uh
perhaps infected and uh infected with I
don't know I mean I didn't do too much
asking I really felt good
the president tested positive for
covid-19 two days after the last debate
pushed by NBC Savannah Guthrie he would
not say whether or not he was tested the
day of the debate which had an honor
System requiring both candidates be
tested I don't know I don't even
remember I test all the time you don't
know if you got a test on the day of the
day no problem again the doctors do it I
don't ask them I test all the time did
you take a test on the day of the debate
I guess I probably did and I took the
test the day before and the day before
and I was always in great shape so just
stick a button that do take a test every
single day no no but I take a lot of
tests okay and you don't know if you
took a test the day of the debate uh uh
possibly I did possibly I didn't who do
you owe 421 million dollars Mr Trump
appeared to confirm a New York Times
report that he does in fact go over 400
million dollars possibly to foreign
entities 400 million dollars compared to
the assets that I have all of these
great properties all over the world
confirming that yes you do owe some 400
million dollars the thing is that it's a
tiny percentage of my net worth no I
don't owe Russia money I don't know I
owe a very very small it's 12 mortgages
people have a house foreign Bank any
foreign
because it's so easy to solve and if
you'd like to do I will let you know who
who I owe whatever small amount of money
let me ask you about Q Anon in a
shocking exchange the president
repeatedly refused to denounce Q Anon a
movement the FBI identified as a
potential domestic Terror threat this
theory that
Democrats are a satanic pedophile ring
and that you are the savior of that
now can you just once and for all state
that that is completely not true
in its entirety I know nothing about a q
Anon I just talked I know very little
you told me but what you tell me doesn't
necessarily make it fact I hate to say
that I know nothing about it but he then
seemed to promote part of their Central
belief the baseless conspiracy theory
about a secret cabal of pedophiles
waging an anti-trump war from inside the
government what I do here about it is
they are very strongly against
pedophilia and I agree with that I mean
I do agree with that and I agree with
it's not a satanic uh pedophile
do you know that
after repeatedly refusing to commit to a
peaceful transfer of power the president
said last night that he would and with
millions of Americans already voting he
continued to push debunked theories
about voter fraud Anthony Nicole thank
you